>> Hi, YouTube.
I'm Rajesh Shah.
I'm from India and I'm here at the Davos program.
I had been attending a number of sessions
which I related to how to
become to this past as far as my nations are
concerned in the economy.
And to me it's really fascinating that we
have a well-off, incredibly
intelligent and important people.
How do they allow trillions and trillions
of dollars to be wiped out.
And I went to one session yesterday and key
thing that seems to be
coming out of this date, the kind of completely
ignoring the lessons of
history and what happens when greed is allowed
to go completely a mock
as across and the kind of bonuses given to
people to sell junk.
There are many many angry opponents but just
to think we have so many
people educated so expensively and with so
much experience, Nobel Prize
winners, they worked together could not get
this avoided.
This whole problem. They must have seen whether
we are going to have
growth, 1 percent or 2 percent in the world
but it looks like a very
difficult time at least next five or ten years.
Thank you.